i wanted to share something new i've
been working on uh it started around
february 2021 where i was struck with
this idea of blending both an online
course a public exhibition an internship
or field trip all into one experience as
a part of the problem i always like to
think of a big linear narrative people
travel through
and this was spurred by
frustration with what i saw being done
in the world of online learning
especially during the lockdowns and what
annoyed me most was seeing my own kids
being forced to use technology backwards
not as a tool but as a hurdle
but the big realization for me is that
most industries now operate fully remote
so taking advantage of that and peeking
behind the scenes of any industry in the
world would be easier than ever
and i think the seed i kept coming back
to was the anti-master class which is
kind of a bait and switch in my opinion
where they sell access to your heroes
and what you get is paywall videos
i think about two years ago i was
browsing user reviews of the platform
and
and noticed someone said like the best
part of masterclass was when they got a
comment from someone else in the section
in the comment section on their work
and this felt like kind of a golden
nugget which is that rich user to user
interaction which powers most online
products was missing mainly from online
education or just bolted on
almost everyone i've worked with always
thought of the online community as
secondary to something else the lecture
the multiple choice question the
interactive simulator and the proof was
in the pudding even today no online
course the traditional ones can retain
their users why didn't kids want to
watch videos and do multiple choice
tests even when we had bells and
whistles added on but ultimately it was
mainly about telling so our approach
would be to shift the focus on doing so
our idea is simple what if we designed a
product entirely around making your work
better
every decision on the product would
would answer that question if it doesn't
make your work better we don't need it
and to focus this point slightly what if
we made a program that helped you make
industry-grade prototypes because in a
world where your portfolio is much more
important than your resume this does
seem like the obvious direction
here is the first napkin sketch of this
idea which i kept and the first was
taking the best of school and work and
finding that intersection the second
idea was using the industry prototype
whether it is a game prototype a script
a business pitch
a story reel as the goal post so that
our user builds a mental model for how
prototypes are designed and made in
various industries including the roles
involved i think of this as like if the
user had a parent who worked in that
industry
then they would naturally absorb that
mental model from your parent and so
imagine you had 50 parents in every
industry at all times
what that could do for your future the
third is that the real world work it
happens in teams it requires feedback
and iteration and it's eventually
consumed at a deadline which is where
this idea of exhibition is part of the
process
and so what this product would do is
push people ahead towards being excited
about making x and knowing their role in
that process of creation
and giving all young people access to
this kind of guidance and mentorship as
early as possible would brighten the
future for all
in the past few months we rapidly built
our first prototype of this idea and
designed a new platform from scratch to
accomplish it and so story experiential
allows you to follow the pixar process
for nine weeks to create a prototype of
your own original short film and this
program has the following cadence where
each week you work on a deliverable that
leads you towards the final goal of a
finished prototype
and the pattern is on monday there is a
live session with a different pixar
industry host or two who speak to your
work ahead take live questions and do
some feedback and modeling and then
during the week users work
asynchronously inside their teams or
across teams using our community tools
to get to their weekly deliverable which
they upload on friday or into the
weekend and the really fun part is on
friday people start uploading their work
in progress to our system which leads to
the real engine of our program the
weekly gallery it's a fire hose of work
which everyone in the program is sharing
and critically every user in the program
reviews several other pieces of work so
nobody is ignored and we do that with a
randomizing system in a sorting system
we're still experimenting with the best
way to do this but it is working so far
so every user wakes up monday morning
with their own dedicated page with their
work in progress at the top
and a stream of feedback at the bottom
and so instead of handing in your work
to your teacher to get a check mark it
goes out to peers you don't know
and care about your work which i think
is really interesting
and one of the big surprises is the
gallery acts as the teacher it's way
better than what one person can do
because you're absorbing the work of
hundreds or thousands of people both
conceptually and technically getting
ideas and it ends with the final
exhibition which is the capstone to each
kind of session where all the users get
a dedicated page and a public gallery
kind of netflix style and we do user
choice awards celebration videos
and industry reaction videos to the top
work and now we're still brainstorming
the potential of what this exhibition
can be because this is basically a fire
hose of talent which is being
self-selected and coming out and so
we're imagining in the future being able
to connect people to internships jobs
scholarship opportunities and the
potential becomes enormous when you
imagine doing this experiential model in
game design in music and all these other
areas and finally scale this is where
things get exciting most mentorship
programs make the mistake of physical
mentorship where they think oh we'll get
one expert and 10 kids one expert and 50
kids but our model is designed to allow
one mentor to end people at very low
cost and so far this has required some
clever design and technology
but i'm convinced it can scale based on
our first pilot which we did with about
500 students of all the students who
started the program over 90
completed
which was beyond even our most rosy
projections and it speaks to the fact
that the mechanisms in this program are
working our next step is to scale it up
to many many thousand and see what we
learn and now we're about to launch our
second session new and improved for both
under 18 and over 18 which will keep us
separate cohorts and what i would just
love is more feedback about how to make
this program better and the way to do
that is to have people do the program
and tell us how to make it better so i
invite you to check it out um and if not
you maybe you know someone that would
this is up the rally for their kids or
adults you know who may want to try it
and would be happy to basically just
stream feedback here below this video
and i'll respond to everything so thank
you so much
think of your favorite pixar film
it all starts with a great story
and every great story starts with a team
of storytellers
[Music]
we all tell stories
it's part of everyday life
but how do you turn storytelling into a
career
story experiential with pixar lets you
find out firsthand
through this eight-week program you
won't just see what it's like to work at
pixar you'll do it yourself you can make
a really simple storyboard with very
little animation and tell a great story
but you can also make a beautifully
animated short that has a terrible story
and we think it's more important to have
a good story
here you'll create a story reel for your
own original concept following the same
process that pixar artists use to
develop their movies when you're doing
storyboarding to develop a shorthand for
your character i think it's really
helpful to think about reaction better
than oxygen this is why we edit you are
arming yourself with some story clippers
and you're trimming cutting shaping and
refining your reels into the shape that
you want them to be with weekly guidance
and support from the people at pixar
you'll discover what it takes to tell a
great story
you're creating a memory of like what
happened but so often when you tell a
story
you're creating a feeling
but no one's looking at the degree they
don't need to see your degree to be an
artist right
what they want to see that they want to
feel
is the passion the love that you have
for what you do working in groups you'll
learn the essential skills of giving and
receiving feedback not to mention the
importance of iteration
at the end you'll walk away with a
finished story reel for your portfolio
and the opportunity to have your work
seen at a final exhibition
you'll discover that there's more to
storytelling than writing there's more
to art than drawing
because ultimately the best way to know
whether a job is right for you
is to experience it for yourself